I try to practice what I preach in my class,
or practice what I teach in my class, which
is that learning happens not from me telling
things to students, but from them experiencing
things.
And I want them to be able to enable that
with their own students, and I'm trying to
do that in my own class with my students.
So, on the first day of class, I might give
a lecture for 20 minutes about what the class
is about, and that's pretty much it for lecturing
for me for the rest of the semester.
So, we do a lot of stuff that's discussion-based
and activity-based.
I do try to have, I don't think constructivism-From
my perspective, I'm not a radical constructivist
who says, "Everything needs to be learned
by the students on their own."
But it's a matter of having, figuring out
what those experiences are, how to design
them, and then how to engage in conversation
and reflection based on those experiences
to have students learn about what it means
to teach and what it means to learn.
So it's about constructing those right situations
that I think hopefully foster learning, and
we do change that year after year after we
realize, "Well, this didn't work so well this
year.
Maybe we'll change it for next year.
Maybe we'll get rid of this and replace it
with something else."
And then it's a matter of figuring out, for
any particular group of students, where I
interject myself into the conversation--where
I have to sort of ask a critical question,
or where I have to offer an opinion, or where
I kind of just let the conversation go where
it may.
"Some people really like to talk, and some
people really don't like to talk.
So sometimes I just let that naturally evolve,
and try to be able to gauge whether there's
some people who are not talking who would
like to be talking, or who could benefit from
talking.
One of the reasons why we sort of rotate the
responsibilities is that it makes sure that
at least at some point for each activity you're
up at the front of the room.
You're in charge of a Current Events.
You're in charge of a Chapter Reading.
You're in charge of teaching a lesson.
So there are a lot of opportunities where
you're required to sort of be engaged at the
front of the room, or centrally in the room,
even if you're not at the front.
And I think that that tries to break down
some of the barriers in terms of why some
people don't participate in the class, why
they sit in the back and are quiet.
Once they sort of have that opportunity to
come to the front, some of those barriers
are broken down and they're more willing to
participate.
I don't typically cold-call on people, but
we do break up into groups, so sometimes when
students are reluctant to talk in a group
of 25, they're much more willing when everybody
in the group needs to talk with each other.
The Modes of Teaching activity allows us to
do student teaching but in a way that gets
everybody engaged and thinking about this.
And I think one of the things that students
come into the class thinking is that, "Well,
the most efficient way to teach is to get
up at the front of the room and talk to people.
And I'll tell them that, and I can cover so
much in an hour.
It's really great."
And then it's a matter of having them think
about, well, what are the benefits of using
other activities?
What are the benefits of having people do
things hands-on?
What are the benefits of using other media
and hands-on activities that you might do
with even a small group of students at the
front of the room?
And how those fit together.
It's not to say that one of them is better
than the other, but it's to think about, what
are the ways they fit together, and what are
the ways they engage you in different ways?
So, it gets people thinking about, what are
the merits of these different things?
And then also, how do they fit together in
ways that may not be obvious?
Because it's... sometimes people think about
the lecture as the thing that should go first:
"I should tell them the stuff, and then they
should rehearse it in a lab or an activity."
And the way we mix it up, sometimes that comes
first.
Sometimes the lecture comes first, and sometimes
the activity or lab comes first.
And it's about understanding, "Wow, that really...
diving right into it really gave me some context
for this.
And then when I went to the lecture the next
class period, it actually made a lot more
sense because I had already done this activity
where the... that lecture was put into some
sort of context."